alarm in der kleinen gemeinde severin in
mecklenburg vorpommern eine feuerschutz
übung steht an
innerhalb weniger minuten ist die
freiwillige feuerwehr einsatzbereit
mittendrin die 31 jährige iris reckling
die wie alle hier ehrenamtlich arbeitet
das
eine versuchung
immer wenn die sirene wird kribbelt
immer alles wann kommt das adrenalin und
dann eigentlich nur bei der sache hier
auch am einsatzort atemschutzgeräte
müssen angelegt werden
iris reckling überprüft permanent den
luftdruck
zum glück ist alles nur eine übung im
ernstfall wäre es hier um ein reh
gegangen solche übungen für die
freiwillige feuerwehr von severin
mehrmals im jahr durch einen klick bei
der feuerwehr zu sein ist es auch bei
den einsätzen zu wissen dass man
jemanden jetzt aus der grenzenlose
freiheit oder das feuer gelöscht hat
wenn er zum beispiel jetzt tote sind es
ist kein krieg mehr für mich da hat mit
den bildern hat noch ganz ganz lange zu
kämpfen und zu tun
ihr geld verdient ihres reckling in
einem integrativen kindergarten
sie betreut kinder die eine behinderung
haben wollte eigentlich polizei
mecklenburg vorpommern ist das am
dünnsten besiedelte bundesland
deutschlands nur 1,6 millionen menschen
leben hier betrachten haben wir ein
bisschen über 800 gemeinden rund 1000
feuerwehren und davon sind genau sechs
berufsfeuerwehren wenn man das also mal
entfällt ist sieht dann sieht man da
überwiegende teil ist auf
ehrenamtlichkeit aufgebaut und so
funktioniert unsere system ja schon über
150 jahre
doch viele junge menschen ziehen wegen
fehlender arbeitsplätze aus dieser
regierung weg zurück bleiben die älteren
das betrifft auch die freiwilligen
feuerwehren sie haben nachwuchssorgen
deshalb versucht ihres reckling als
frauenbeauftragte junge menschen zu
gewinnen
es ist jetzt schon abzusehen wer keine
jugendabteilung hat in der feuerwehr
den gibt es in 20 jahren auch nicht der
wird dann schließen müssen weil die
einsatzkräfte einfach nicht mehr
nachrücken
es ist auch ganz wichtig auch viel
unterwegs zu sein und eigentlich so
jedes fest mitzunehmen dass man so mit
kriegen kann ein feuerwehrfest in
rostock für iris reckling ein idealer
ort um nachwuchs zu werben
sie selbst ist noch ledig trotzdem ist
es nicht selbstverständlich dass sie
fast jedes wochenende fürs ehrenamt
unterwegs ist ein malbuch dann kannst du
dir einfach mal herkommen mitmachen ein
soll was ein armband ein rotes also ist
total wichtig auf die unter
sechsjährigen zu kriegen weil die haben
meistens schon total das faible für
feuerwehr und die sind natürlich feuer
und flamme dafür das ist natürlich
leichter die dann als sechsjähriger in
die feuerwehr also in die bambini
feuerwehr reinzubekommen
es muss noch viel aufs feuer ihr
hauptaugenmerk den mädchen und natürlich
den frauen sie sollen verstärkt
angeworben werden
nur rund acht prozent aller mitglieder
der freiwilligen feuerwehr sind weiblich
ich denke mal das ist natürlich noch
viele vorurteile gekühlt bei der
feuerwehr abläuft also immer nur trinken
oder das ist eine eingeschworene verein
ist das ist glaube ich alles ohne
vorurteile und die versuche ich so
allmählich abzubauen
iris reckling seit 14 jahren ist sie bei
der freiwilligen feuerwehr und sie will
es noch lange bleiben